[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
fan corrections uh this is of course a
segment where viewers try to find
mistakes on our show
good luck
so far there have been many challengers
i think there have been maybe a hundred
challengers no winners
we don't make mistakes
well tonight a fan named gary goltz
thinks he caught us making a mistake he
claims that during my recent interview
with tenacious d
jack black
did something wrong take a look
i'm gary galtz i'm a seventh degree
black belt in judo i run the one of the
biggest judo clubs in the u.s i'm also
the president of the united states judo
association and i'm here to tell you
that you definitely had a mistake on
your show tenacious dd's fall
what he called the tiger roll which is
the forward and kemi in judo was totally
incorrect you have a signature move jack
the mini tiger roll it's something i
learned in judo
he landed him properly with his legs as
i'll show you right now uh ashley come
up here please did you please show the
legs
you can see the way she's putting her
leg behind her in the back very
dangerous very sloppy not code con
international judo standard definitely
not olympic judo standard this is
something all my basic beginners learn
and uh your your guest jack black
tenacious t really needs to take a
refresher course in judo and you need to
correct this for all your fans to know
that it was done the improper way thank
you
[Applause]
what an [ __ ]
sorry
i am sorry
is he holding those kids hostage
that's the most depressing class i've
ever seen
over there while i yell at this camera
you certainly well he he understands
that this show is first and foremost
about correct judo
well anyway i am sorry gary if that's
even your real name
i just threw that in uh
but your beef is not with me it's with
jack black
so i forwarded jack your video
he gave it a look and he is responding
right now here is his response
gary goats 7th degree black belt
it's me jack black 423rd degree black
belt if i would you take issue with
something you just said
the tiger roll the tiger roll is gonna
roll right over you
you say my tiger roll is very dangerous
you damn straight your tiger roll is
tame like a tiger in the zoo it sped
slabs of beef by a guy wearing khaki my
tiger roll is a wild beast living in the
jungles of nepal it feasts on villagers
the tiger roll the tiger roll is gonna
roll out for you
you say my tiger roll doesn't meet coda
khan and olympic standards you're right
they both banded as have the fbi the
mafia and nasa for being too kick-ass
the tiger roll attack roll is
your tiger roll is just a big [ __ ] cat
gary i do the tiger roll you do the
[ __ ] roll
the tiger roll the tiger frozen freaking
rolled over
you lose carrot coats
[Music]
[Applause]
wow
check flex a busy guy he's a newbie star
i know he he took three weeks off to
answer that
he let us shoot in his apartment that
was amazing
anyway our thanks to jack and the
challenge still stands if you think
you've spotted an error on our show
report at teamcocoa.com
haha i found an error we will sort it
out right here on the air let's see if
you've got what it takes to make chunk
meat out of the maestro all right